(door closes)
("Consistency" by TruthCity)
- I started my
business because of you.
- [Gary] Yes. I saw that.
That was awesome.
(crosstalk)
- Got a partner,
we're now launching.
Did a vlog, I was one page
in #AskGaryVee I was like
I got to do something.
Started a vlog,
got an ambassador for the
city, made a whole bunch of
business connections,
digging into social. Huge.
- [Gary] Makes me happy man.
You're welcome.
- Selfie?
- [Gary] Yeah.
Awesome, man.
Yeah, continued success.
- DRock, you're the man.
- [Jill] Hey. How are you doing?
- [Gary] Hi.
- [Jill] Jill.
- [Gary] Jill. How are you?
- [Jill] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Awesome.
- Perfect, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(crosstalk)
I made the connection.
Yeah, how are things?
- [Man] Good.
- [Gary] Yeah, all well?
Good.
- [Man 2] One of the
things we're finding is,
I know the vendors out here will
agree with some of the dealers,
is there's this change
of narrative on metrics.
What's working
what's not working.
Which metrics to
look at, which metrics--
- Sales of fucking cars.
(audience laughter and applause)
And the way you do that is by
suffocating the marketing.
I want to be in a
bake-off with your stuff.
My picture can say
ask for Rick or call,
do you guys know how to
get Google phone numbers?
Get a bunch of
Google phone numbers,
use Twilio, make all
your separate marketing call a
different phone number
and then measure it.
Not only that 'cause
calls aren't sales of cars.
Then follow through,
which you might get
eighty calls from Facebook.
You might get 130 phone calls
from the radio but if you sell
one car from the radio and seven
from Facebook 'cause the data
you targeted were people
actually in the god damn market
to buy a car.
The reason you guys spend so
much money is you're always
spending 'cause
you never know when the
person's in consideration.
Facebook has data of people
searching to buy cars and you
can get in their feed.
I mean what's the
matter with people?
I'll tell you what's the matter.
You don't know
that truth that I know.
You didn't know that.
You know that Facebook, you
think the stuff that came out
the other day about
the FBI and the CIA like
hacking everything, that, yes.
Just assume everybody's
looking at you at all times.
Privacy is dead.
You are naked.
You don't like it?
Stop using your phone.
Let's see how long you last.
So, yes, it's a
huge advantage and so,
you know, the metric
is selling cars, man.
- [Man 2] Yep.
- The reason I want to pay an
Instagram influencer who's like
good-looking ab dude or booty
chick is 'cause I know 4,000
people will show up to my
dealership and three of them
might buy a car and I'm
willing to make that bet.
I have to at least taste it.
I want to see
what it looks like.
How are you not curious?
- [Man 2] You touched on the--
- Let me tell you how you do it.
(audience laughter)
You go into Instagram
you search a hashtag
like whatever,
you can just search.
Actually you search, I'm sorry,
you go into Instagram,
there's a search bar up top.
You search by location.
So you put in your
zip code, your town,
it shows you the 12 most
trending pictures within a
one mile radius of
your god damn town.
You then look at
all the pictures,
I promise you seven of them
are attractive, scantily clad,
the other five
are something else.
But you click on them, you see
how many followers they have.
They're global,
it's not like all their
followers are from Alpharetta.
You know, like
they're all over the place.
But you click on them and then
there's a triple little button
in the top right corner.
That's how you message people.
You click it, you DM the person.
You say, I own a car dealership.
I'd like to pay you to show
up at my car dealership this
Saturday from 12 to 4 and you
tell your Instagram followers.
They'll reply,
they'll say, "How much?"
You say I have no idea some
weird guy told me to do this.
How much is it?
They give you an answer
and then you take a risk.
You may lose $600.
You may crap your pants when
they ask you for $50,000 and you
realize how real this
is and you keep playing.
And then you try
and then you learn.
When you're a pioneer,
you have to taste it.
There's no report,
there's no white paper,
there's no modeling mix metrics
that are gonna teach you how
that's gonna work.
When you're the first explorer,
you have to taste the berries
and hopefully
they're not poisonous.
- [Man 2] Good stuff. Questions.
Do we have some
questions from out here?
Want to make sure...
("Consistency" by TruthCity)
(audience applause)
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- My name is Nelly.
- [Gary] How are you?
Good to see you.
- And I came from
Soviet Union, too.
- I love it.
- Please say something to me.
- Hey everybody. One life.
Don't worry about
your accent, just do you.
Your truth is your truth.
They'll love you as
long as it's your truth.
(speaking Russian)
- [Man 3] Two, I want a Flip
Challenge leaderboard 'cause
I've already tripled it.
- [Gary] You're
really at that number?
My man.
That's awesome.
You made this?
- [Man 4] My brother-in-law.
- Dude.
- How you doing?
- [Gary] You got
some real talent, man.
(laugh) That's awesome man.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Let's get a picture.
- [Gary] Yeah.
VaynerMedia is fearless because
I'm fearless and I'm in charge.
So, it's one in the same.
It's always fear.
It's the fear of the unknown.
It's short term thinking
versus long term thinking.
It's acting like the world's
ending tomorrow when for the far
majority of us
we'll be here 30, 40,
50, 60 years from now.
What CEOs and business owners
have done a good job with,
especially in big companies,
is somehow manipulate the
conversation that
it's not their fault.
- Mhmmm.
- Like, who's fault is it?
It's his fault.
It's my fault.
If you're in
charge of your shit,
it's your fault.
- That's right.
- So, no I don't see a
difference between people and
organizations 'cause the
organization is following the
lead of the
singular decision maker.
Bye, bye.
- [Woman 2] Thank you.
- [Gary] Good luck, man.
- [Bianca] I'm an artist.
- [Gary] Go ahead, go ahead.
- I'm just a graphic
designer and starting a
business right now.
- Put your art to
the world at scale.
- At scale.
- I mean every god damn
day on every platform always.
- Mhmmm.
- You're always
one Instagram post,
one Facebook post,
one Snapchat post,
one blog post away from
somebody thinking it's great.
- Alright.
- Does that make sense?
- Yes, it does.
I know a lot of people--
- Do you do that? Bottling?
- Buying followers.
- That's the stupidest.
Buying followers is the single
stupidest thing to do because,
I'll tell you why.
It gets you nothing other
than perception meanwhile
everybody's smart.
Like nobody who's ever bought
a follower has ever tricked me
that they bought followers.
So what happens when you buy
followers is the top 10% of
smartest people who can bring
you the most value in the world
think that you're a scam artist.
- Yeah, yep.
- So maybe you
tricked the bottom 10%.
So when you buy
followers, DRock. Yep.
- Thanks Gary.
- [Gary] Take care guys.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome, bro.
- [Man 5] You got time
for one more handshake?
- Hell yeah.
Thank you, man.
- [Man 5] I appreciate
your time.
- Stay well. Thank
you guys, take care.
Buying followers
is insanity. You know?
- Mhmmm.
- You're worried
about other people.
- [Woman 3] Yes.
I'm definitely worried.
I'm worried they're gonna judge
me and I'm embarrassed about my
follower count right now.
- Don't. We all started there.
- Yes.
- You're wrapping your
self esteem into following count
is a huge mistake.
Don't buy followers,
don't cut corners.
You got to be patient.
You're such a baby.
- [Bianca] I'm 22.
- You're fucking crazy.
Don't worry about that.
You got to care
about stay inside yourself.
I respect you so much more for
having 97 followers that are
yours than somebody who bought
a bunch and I can tell 'cause
their engagement rate is shit
compared to how many followers
they have.
Do you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, I do.
Those guys they don't talk to
their followers or anything.
- Patience.
- Got it.
- Patience and inside
yourself. Nobody else.
Inside yourself, patience.
That's it.
- Awesome.
Thanks Gary. It was
really nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- My name's Bianca.
- Bye, Bianca.
- Have a good one.
- [Man 6] Amazing job, Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you guys.
Take care. Have safe travels.
("Money Won't Last"
by Fiifi Jr.)
That Honey Empire runs
all the way through, right?
At this point...
As you guys know,
60 Second Club,
lot of t-shirts, lot of books
but also a lot of two and five
minute Face Times so I'm
about three in right now,
I'm about to do
Ajab. Here we go.
Ajab Baparra Jandalla.
Listen, Vaynerchuk
gets butchered too.
You're an engineer.
That's right, makes sense.
You're practical
and entrepreneurship...
I would tell you to
level up your thinking.
I wouldn't think about it as
weddings and as birthday I would
think of your main
thing as calligraphy.
So I just went on a
huge email storm I guess.
Email rant to the whole company.
Like how many
did you get, DRock?
- [DRock] Like 12.
- 12?
I sent like 54 emails
to the whole company
and it was great.
Just huge communication thing
about speed and efficiency.
Some of you
might've saw my tweet.
That started it,
then it got going.
I just got a lot done in an hour
and a half on email that will
impact our company
for a long time.
It's nice, huh?
- [DRock] Gorgeous.
(whistle blowing)
- [Avi] What's up, gents?
- By the way for
everybody at home,
this whole to do
about the amazing weather
it's 59 in New York.
Feel like people'd
be dead in L.A.
("Money Won't Last"
by Fiifi Jr.)
Very Top Secret.
Obviously, there's
like the books.
It's always one of my cheapest.
My desperate-est.
You've always been very smart to
trade on me during those times
and I've actually always admired
that and thought that was smart.
Give it some thought and I'm
gonna always jam with you.
Number two, and
this was interesting,
do you guys have an agency or
do you do all your creative
marketing and
media work internally?
Love it, brother.
Talk to ya. Bye.
Four minutes.
Two monster things.
Fucking put both times there.
Start, done.
Put some music
'cause it's freaking super.
Try to sneak a word or two in.
Four minutes,
two monster things.
Not 15, not 30.
Not presentations,
not PDFs, human words,
four minutes,
execution.
See ya later.
Hello.
- Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
Good to see you.
How are you?
- Paul, pleasure.
- Such a pleasure.
Real pleasure, how are you?
- Yeah, fantastic.
Thanks for having us.
- How are you?
Such a pleasure.
Trilled to have you.
- This is a really nice place.
- How's it going so far?
Hey.
- [Man 7] Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Man 7] Yeah, definitely.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
- [Group] Hi!
- [Gary] How are you?
See ya later.
Hello.
Yo, yo!
'Sup guys?
Fantastic. You?
- [Woman 3] Great!
- [Gary] Yo!
- [Sam] 'Sup?
- [Gary] What up, Sam?
What's up Kenny?
How are you? Good.
Just a couple emails.
I'm on it.
I'm feeling good about myself.
Yeah. Real pleasure, man.
How are you?
Yes. Real pleasure, man.
Thank you, man.
Two in 14, man.
Listen, I'll take one half
day in return for what it does.
'Sup Staats?
My arch-nemisis the only
person that has a prayer
of beating me this year.
It's gonna be me and you, kiddo.
Barring injuries.
Hey guys.
Hey, how are you?
Choice, you
want to make a trade?
Alright, I'm open for business.
- Hello, sir.
- [Gary] Hey.
How are you?
You started in July?
- Yeah.
- You need to send Tyler
an email for us to sit down.
- Yeah.
- Like right now.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Okay, I really want to.
- Me too.
That clearly fell
through the cracks.
We'll sit down next week.
- Okay. Awesome man.
- Cool.
'Sup gang? How's life?
(indistinct chatter)
Feel really good.
Got some things off my chest.
Feeling good.
Does everybody need to
be in the this meeting?
- Yes.
(Gary laughs)
- [Gary] Now this is
a good looking meeting.
This is a good looking meeting.
This is the kind
of meeting I like.
("Consistency" by TruthCity)
- This is a very good number.
Empty conference rooms.
All of a sudden we
have empty conference rooms.
- [Man 8] Crazy, right?
- [Gary] Crazy
how that works out.
This is a nice looking
meeting, two human beings.
Feel great.
- [Man 9] Feeling good.
- Feeling great.
- [Man 9] And I just wanted you
to come in the Boston office.
- [Gary] Yeah, I
didn't know about this.
- DRock, can you get
this in the background?
- Yeah, you can get
it in the background.
- Can we get a thumbs up?
A thumbs up?
- No, no.
Celtics actually don't really
bother me to be very honest.
Really don't.
Brandon Marshall's a Giant.
More upsetting than the Celtics.
Oh my god, this is insane.
- [DRock] Aw.
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
This is really cool.
Ice, this is my life story.
We're probably
going to have to frame it.
- [DRock] Yeah,
needs to be framed.
- [Gary] Let's frame it.
Who made it?
- Let me get his social for you.
- [Gary] Okay.
Hold it up real quick.
It's a quilt, right?
- [Sean] Yeah.
- This thing is insane.
About to give a shoutout to the
wonderful person that made it.
Sick.
Preview to Biz Dev Sunday,
it's gonna be the main theme.
VaynerMedia doing
an Alumni program.
One of the great things about
this company is we have so many
incredible people
who after three,
four, five years or sometimes
even after six months or after
working at agency 15 years and
were six months here and they
know this is the pinnacle and
they're like oh it wasn't my
agency it's just
that agency life.
Lot of small businesses.
A lot of large businesses.
We're creating
an incredible thing.
Part of the Honey Empire an
internal Alumni program where
people can raise their hand.
All these startups
I'm involved with.
All of you.
People who are looking
for talent, our way,
this whole digital
2017 camp thing that
we've been talking about.
The tours, the $10,000 a
head, this is another layer.
Another big idea.
Alumni program, if you're a
company that's looking to hire
unbelievable
talent all disciplines,
it's gonna be cool.
When somebody comes to us or
when we decide
somebody's not part of
the team any more we're gonna
put them in this alumni funnel
and they're gonna shoot out.
It's gonna be really cool.
I'm pretty excited about
changing the way HR and
job hunting and the whole thing
works and so a quick little
preview in today's
DailyVee for what
you'll definitely see Sunday.
("Money Won't Last"
by Fiifi Jr.)
Sushi place on
the left here? Yeah?
- Could it be? GaryVee!
- [Gary] How are you?
Such a pleasure.
- [Woman 4] How are you,
buddy? Feel like I know you.
- [Other Tyler] Hi, I'm Tyler.
- [Woman 4] The famous Tyler.
- [Gary] Yes, Tyler's here.
This is not the Tyler
you've been talking to.
That's Tyler Schmitt.
- There's so many Tylers.
- [Other Tyler] We
have a lot of Tylers.
- [Gary] We have
multiple Tylers.
- This Tyler is not as...
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
- [Woman 5] Is it three then?
He's just filming
a little B-roll and
that's it for my vlog.
But if that's not
okay, that's fine.
- [Man 11] It is not permitted.
- [Gary] Awesome.
Then he's not doing it.
- [Man 11] No, we can
always arrange stuff like that.
- [Gary] Dude, it's so--
- Alright, we're out. (laughs)
- Super not an issue.
(crosstalk)
Hang with him and
I'll catch up with you.
- [Other Tyler] Man, it'd be so
crazy if we could actually put
everything out there.
Like the real, the real stuff.
- I want you to keep
that part in this episode.
The real stuff.
Yep, I'm giving it to you 97%
real what Bain's talking about
is the insanely difficult shit
I'm dealing with I can't share
because
it's just involving
people's lives and it's
inappropriate for me to do so.
Now, that being said,
it's important for me to
continue to reference it.
I do for you guys so
that you guys know that.
There's just nothing but
adversity and difficulty.
I often say I'm a firefighter.
When you're the CEO
it's all your fault.
Everything's on you and
yeah.
And I think what's interesting
and the reason I'm gonna use
this clip is your
perspective's interesting
because it's fresh eyes.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- You're like oh,
this is what it is.
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
(Gary and Tyler laugh)
- It's real shit.
Grass is always greener.
Two people.
- Yep.